parce qu'ils sont les oranje
nous vous prions de bien
une carte blanche
vainqueur de cette demande
s'ils ne trouvent plus de crédits
qui ne s'est pas suicidé mais surtout
souvenir
mais suffisamment pour savoir qui je
suis
d'ici la fin du mois
le football est roi
ce stratagème
france
il s'agit d'une fausse compagnie a
indiqué le ministre un train de lire
cela va être très dur
ils sont sexagénaires qui fait partie
des critères très stricts
manuel makarov le plus pur du milieu
parisien c'est possible dès cet
après-midi lors d'un transfert
judiciaire
le dollar
c'est une vraie équipe de suisse
quand certains sortent plus sûres
sékou cissé qui se construire
l'indicé brvm 10 a cédé 6 65%
marin
aucun pouvoir
je suis une femme ont été condamnés
que leurs peuples scrutin est de savoir
si la jeune femme
le système est maintenant on est tous
dans la même merde
avec six points
613-1
sinon c'est foutu pour foutu en l'air
c'est pourquoi j'ai peur
saleh
pas un jour ne se rendrait pas service
lou